Good morning church.
It is a joy to be with you guys today. Um, happy 60 years.
What a blessing it is, um, to hear all those stories.
Oh, my name is Brandon. I get
to serve here at Henderson Hills in the student ministry,
working with sixth to 12th graders.
And it is an absolute ball.
Uh, and also I get to devote some of my time as a resident.
I get to grow in the areas of pastoral ministry
and church planting.
And so I'm super excited about that
and what the future holds.
But if you're new here, I just wanna say welcome.
This is a very big space.
It can be intimidating at times, but we don't want it to be.
We want to connect with you, we want to meet you.
And so, uh, after service you, if you want to go out
to the lobby, there is a new here sign.
Uh, we'd love to get connected
and also come up to the front, uh, for prayer.
And we just love to talk to you.
Uh, but if you have your Bibles, please turn with me
to First Corinthians.
We are going to be in first Corinthians 10 this morning
right after Romans, right
before second Corinthians,
one Corinthians 10 in the New Testament.
So as you're turning there, I just want to give you guys,
uh, a quick summary of what this month has been for us.
It's been a big one in the life of Henderson Hills.
We get to celebrate 60 years as you guys saw,
and as we look back at our history,
one thing has been truly evident
and that is God's faithfulness.
Without God, none of us would mean anything.
The truth is, if God doesn't show up,
then we are wasting our time and working in vain.
And God's faithfulness is not an attribute that we came up
with or we discovered,
but it is something that's been revealed to us
through his word.
And we can see it all throughout the Bible,
God's faithfulness.
But what we've done the past couple weeks
is we've honed in on first Corinthians
and we've tried to see all the times.
Paul mentions how God is faithful.
And this morning we get to see
that God is faithful in our temptations.
How encouraging is that?
In our weakest moments when we feel all alone,
God is faithful.
God is faithful to provide a way of escape so
that we can endure it.
And I myself have truly thought sometimes that the only way
to get past this temptation is to give in
and let the enemy win.
But that is not what the Bible teaches.
What the Bible teaches is that we can fight
and we can win against temptation only
because God is faithful.
And if God is faithful in our temptations
and he wants to see us endure, here's what this tells me,
that God is for you.
God does not want to see sin destroy you.
Do you believe that this morning?
Do you believe in God's faithfulness?
So if you take away one thing
this morning, I want it to be this.
We fight against temptation
by humbling ourselves under the faithfulness of God.
Let's pray and ask that He would help us believe
that this morning, God, you are good
and God you are faithful.
God, would you help us to understand
who you are through your word?
God, I pray that the word of God falls on good soil
and brings back much fruit.
In your name we pray. Amen.
One Corinthians 10, six through 13 says this.
Now, these things took place as examples for us
that we might not desire evil as they did,
do not be idolaters as some of them were as it is written
that people sat down to eat and drink and rose up to play.
We must not indulge in sexual
immorality as some of them did.
And 23,000 fell in a single day.
We must not put Christ to the test as some of them did
and were destroyed by serpents
nor grumble as some of them did
and were destroyed by the destroyer.
Now these things happen to them as an example,
but they're written down
for our instruction on whom the end of ages has come.
Therefore, that anyone who thinks that he,
that he stands take heed lest he fall.
No temptation has overtaken you. That is not common to man.
God is faithful and he will not let you be
tempted beyond your ability.
But with the temptation, he will also provide the way
of escape so that you may be able to endure it.
So this is a fun text and a fun topic to talk about.
I mean, who doesn't love temptation? Right?
Um, and I think it's funny, uh,
and I'm trying to figure out why John would give me
the one about temptation.
Maybe he's trying to send me a message, I'm not sure,
but we can all ask him after this.
Um, but little does John though, that I am actually
an expert when it comes to the temptations.
Um, I know almost every word to my girl
and ain't too proud to beg.
Um, and not only that, my senior year
of high school I took a course, uh, he humanities
where we just studied American culture and history
and the arts and we devoted two weeks
to learning about the Motown crew.
So I guess you could say
that Edna Public School has prepared me
perfectly for this moment.
Go wolves. There we go. Anyone, anyone? There we go.
Uh, but one thing
that we did learn about the temp temptations is this,
and it feels like the case for every, every band,
every boy band in, in history is
that they eventually broke up
and the temptations were no more.
And one of the reasons why most groups break up is due to,
uh, pride and division.
And one member wants to take it this way.
Another member wants to take it this way
and they just can't seem to reconcile and work together.
And once they realize they can no longer work together
anymore, they split up and the band is over.
What's funny about this is that
if we see something very similar to the lives
of the believers in Corinth, there's division among them
and their division is really rooted in being puffed
up and prideful.
And because Paul knows them so well
and he knows the history of those who have gone
before them, he even knows himself so well.
Paul gives them a history lesson
and we see that in verse six.
He says, now these things took place as an example, but,
but what are these things to under understand these things?
We have to go back to verses one through five.
And what is Paul doing? He's pointing them back
to Israel In the wilderness,
God freed the people of Israel from the rule of Pharaoh
and he was bringing them
through the wilderness into the promised land.
And this was no ordinary journey,
but it was a journey that will be talked about
for generations to come.
Paul references how they passed through the Red Sea.
They got to witness God parked the Red Sea
and they walked right through it.
Paul mentioned how the people of Israel,
they were hungry and what did God do?
He provided fruit food from the heavens, not just food,
but he also provided water from a rock.
They got to see all these things.
They got to see God show up in really big ways
and yet they were overthrown in the wilderness.
All their needs are provided by God in a supernatural way.
So you would think that these are the people
who can be puffed up
and handle whatever comes their way, right?
But verse five tells us this, nevertheless, with most
of them, God was not pleased.
Why? For they were overthrown in the wilderness.
What does this show us? What does this
show the Corinthians at the time?
Why is Paul referencing the story?
Because Paul wants them to see that temptation is real
and we are not exempt from that.
Temptation is real and we are not exempt.
Temptation came to tho, came to the fathers.
So they need to see that it will come.
It came to those who walk through the red sea
and it will come to them today and it will come to us.
But if it will come to us
and we're called to fight against it,
what exactly is temptation?
Well, God's word shows us this all throughout the Bible.
We see in Matthew four that Jesus
God in the flesh was tempted himself,
but we also that Jesus was without sin,
which is why he could save us from our sins
by dying for our sins.
So temptation is not sin, we understand that.
But we also see in James chapter one verses 13
and 15, let no one say when he is tempted,
I'm being tempted by God.
For God cannot be tempted with evil
and he himself tempts no one.
But each person is tempted when he is lured
and enticed by his own desire.
Then desire when it has conceived, gives birth to sin.
And sin when it's fully grown, brings forth death.
So temptation is being lured
and enticed by our own desire from within.
And we can't say that God is the one doing the tempting.
One Thessalonians three, five, Paul writes to them, he says,
for this reason when I could bear it no longer I sin
to learn about your faith for fear
that somehow the tempter had tempted you
and our labor would be in vain.
So there is a tempter that is roaming around, desiring
for believers to give in to desires of the flesh
and to destroy themselves.
And the Bible isn't shy to talk about that.
And Paul here in Corinthians wants them
to be on guard and be aware.
Paul wants them to learn from the people of the past,
learn from their mistakes, learn from their examples,
and understand that we are not exempt from that
we will experience temptation
and we need to know what we're up against.
And as I look through this text, I see a lot of commands,
a lot of things not to do.
And I worry verse seven, do not be idol
as some of them were.
I wrestle with the desire inside of me
and I can make idols outta things that are not God.
Verse eight, we must not indulge in sexual immorality.
I wrestle with this with my eyes and my actions.
We must not put Christ to the test.
My fleshly desire
and temptation wants things
to happen the way I want them to happen.
Nor grumble I'm prone to get upset
and to complain when things don't go my way.
And maybe you can relate this morning,
you know the areas you are weak in.
You see the commands laid out in scripture.
You see there is a tempter who wants to entice you
and bring out the desires from within so that you'll give in
and give birth to sin.
And this can be discouraging
because if we are honest with ourselves
and we trust what the Bible says, then we know
that our flesh is weak.
We know our flesh is weak
and we know that from our own experiences
we know that left on our own.
We would constantly, continually give in temptation
and destroy ourselves.
But God is faithful, temptation is real
and we are not exempt
and we are not strong enough to fight it on our own.
But we are not left alone.
We can fight because of God's faithfulness
and his commitment to us.
God wants you to endure temptation
and deny the flesh so
that we might live in the way he designed for us.
So we are not exempt from temptation,
but we are also not exempt from God's faithfulness.
We are not exempt from God's faithfulness. So we have hope.
So what that means is for the father out there
who is tempted to lash out
and yell at his kids, God is faithful in those moments
to help you fight against the flesh
and walk in step with the spirit for the students
who are tempted to idolize themselves
and have a false reality on social media.
God is faithful and he wants you to endure
and flee from temptation.
And the dangers it can lead to for the business owners
and bosses who are wrestling with managing their, their, uh,
managing in unethical ways to keep up
with the ways of the world.
God the Father wants you to know that the way out is by
humbling yourself under his faithfulness.
We are not the ones who pull ourselves out of temptation,
but God is because he is faithful
and he does not want to see us destroy ourselves,
which leads us to our next point.
Without temptation to temptation can lead to sin,
which will lead to death.
Temptation is not what leads to death,
but giving birth to sin is what will destroy us.
We learned that in in James one
and we can even see it in our text very clearly.
Look with me at verse eight again.
We must not indulge in sexual immorality as some of them did
and 23,000 fell in a single day.
Verse nine, we must not put Christ to test
to the test as some of them did
and we're destroyed by serpents verse 10,
nor grumble as some of them did
and were destroyed by the destroyer.
These people did not get to see the promised land
and experience the land flowing with milk and honey
and they died in the wilderness.
Now some of them walked in faithfulness,
but most of them did not.
And God was not pleased giving into the flesh
and giving birth to sin, separated them from God.
And their stories were now written down as an example of
what not to do.
But we see this all throughout the Bible.
We could go back all the way to Genesis three
and see how this played out from the very beginning.
Genesis three, one through six.
Now the serpent was more crafty than any other beast
of the fields that the Lord God had made.
He said to the woman, did God actually say
you shall not eat of any tree in the garden?
And the woman said to the serpent, we may eat of, we may eat
of the fruit of the trees in the garden,
but God said, you shall not eat of the tree.
Eat of the fruit of the tree is in the midst of the garden.
Neither shall you touch it lest you die.
But the serpent said to the woman, you will not surely die
for God knows that when you eat of it,
your eyes will be opened
and you will be like God knowing good and evil.
So when the woman saw that the tree was good for food
and that it was a delight to the eyes that the tree was
to be desired to make one wise, she took
of its fruit and ate.
And she also gave some to her husband who was with her
and he ate the man and the woman gave into into temptation.
And what did it lead to? Separation from God.
And what did it bring? It brought death into the world.
We could look at the story of David,
how he was tempted on the ledge
and he gave into that temptation.
And what did it bring? It brought death
through a generation.
Giving into temptation is destructive.
And there is no one in here who needs to hear
that more than me because I fall into the trap
and think that just because I'm saved by grace
and all my sins have been paid for by the blood of Christ,
I am untouchable.
And it is true and it is good news
that death has no claim on us as believers.
Amen. But when we give into temptation
and sin against God, it still hurts us.
We are hurting our fellowship with God at times.
It can lead to hurting and destroying our own bodies.
Giving in a temptation can lead to hurting those around us
and destroying relationships.
So yes, we are saved and we stand complete,
but we will be foolish to say that giving it a temptation
and sitting against God has no effect on us anymore.
But the most encouraging thing about this text
and topic today is that God is faithful
and he does not want that for us.
He wants the exact opposite.
He wants us to endure temptation.
He wants us to choose him
and his design over our fleshly desires.
And God provides a way of escape a way out of temptation
so we can fight and we can withstand temptation
that comes our way by remembering that he is faithful
and he is for us today.
Do you believe that today? Amen.
Do you believe that the temptation that you are saying yes
to is actually hurting and um, doing damage to you?
But do you also believe that no temptation is uncommon,
meaning that you are not alone in your struggles?
And do you believe that God provides a way out?
And if we believe this,
then we should listen to the command.
And from Paul in verse 14, he says, therefore my beloved
after everything he's just said,
after knowing that God is faithful, what did he say?
He says, therefore, flee from idolatry.
Flee from sin.
You no longer have to sit in your room alone
and just conce the temptation.
You no longer have to walk into work
and just accept this is the way things are going to be.
You no longer have to scroll through social media
and compare yourself to others.
You can fight against temptation against the desires
of the flesh because of who God is.
But here's a challenge of a text like this.
We can become like the famous Duck church.
Have you guys ever heard of the Duck Church?
Do you mind if I tell you about the duck Church?
Um, so once upon a time
in a remote village called Duck Land, um,
there was a small church, um, called Duck Church
and there were no cars in duck church.
And so, uh, all the ducks,
whenever they wanted to go to church, they all waddled.
They waddled their way to the church.
And as soon as they got to the church, they'd come in,
they'd greet each other, it'd be an
amazing time of fellowship.
And if they were new here, they'd waddle themselves
to the new here area in the lobby.
Um, but after they greeted one another, they'd come in
sing these worship songs.
Uh, and the duck minister began to preach.
And the duck preaching would say something along the lines
of this ducks, you were born to fly.
God has given you wings to soar like the eagles.
Ducks fly together, fly as high as you can.
And everyone was encouraged.
Everyone would do their quacks, their amens.
Um, but the truth is once church was over,
they all waddled home.
They all waddled home.
And the truth is, we can come together
and we can hear how we can fight against temptation
because God is faithful and he is for us.
And we can praise him for his faithfulness.
We can thank him that he provides a way of escape.
And then we go back to being oblivious to temptation,
to we go back and try to fight temptation on our own
and we given to sin.
And I don't want that for myself
and I don't want that for us as a collective.
So how are we to escape temptation?
What is the way that God provides?
Now we know that God is sovereign.
It can use many different things for different purposes.
God could usee a phone call from a friend as a way
of escape from temptation.
But what I want us to do is look at three ways
that we see throughout God's word
that he has made a way of escape.
The first one is the Holy Spirit.
In the gospel of John chapters 14
and 16, we see Jesus mention the Holy Spirit
and he tells us that the Holy Spirit is given to us
by God the Father to be with us forever.
And the Spirit serves to teach us all things
and guides us in all things and reveals truth to us.
And for those in here who have put their faith in Jesus,
the spirit of God dwells inside of you.
Now the spirit of God resides in you
to give you strength to flee from temptation
and deny the desires of the flesh.
And this is not our own doing or our own power.
This is God's faithfulness.
So if we want to fight against temptation,
we must humble ourselves under God's faithfulness.
He has given us the spirit of God.
Galatians five 16 and 17 says this,
but I say, walk by the spirit and you'll not gratify.
The desires of the flesh for the desires
of the flesh are against the spirit
and the desires of the Spirit are against the flesh
for these are opposed to each other
to keep you from doing the things you want to do.
Walking as the spirit leads is a way of escape
from the desires of the flesh.
Not only is the spirit of God our help,
but also the word of God.
I mentioned earlier in Matthew four how Jesus was able
to withstand temptation, but how was he able to do it?
We see this in Matthew four verses one through four.
Then Jesus was led up by the Spirit into the wilderness
to be tempted by the devil.
And after fasting, 40 days and 40 nights, he was hungry.
And the tempter came and said to him, if you are the Son
of God, command these stones to become loaves of bread.
But he answered, it is written, man shall not live
by bread alone, but by every word
that comes from the mouth of God.
How did he respond? It is ridden.
He fought against the lies of the enemy with the truths
of the Father.
And he was tempted two more times in this text
and he responds the same way each time.
And we learned this from Psalm 119.
How can a young man keep his way pure
by guarding it according to your word?
With my whole heart, I seek you.
Let me not wander from your commandments.
I have stored up your word in my heart
that I might not sin against you.
So are you making a practice
to write God's word on your heart art?
Do you know his word
and the truths that are found in it so
that you can combat the lives of the enemy?
So we see the spirit of God. We see the word of God.
What else? Prayer. Praying to God.
We know that in Matthew six, in the Sermon on the Mount,
Jesus tells us how to pray.
He teaches us to pray against temptation.
And in Hebrews, we see that Jesus is our great high priest.
And because he is, he's able to sympathize
with us in our weaknesses
because he was tempted just like we are tempted,
yet he was without sin.
So because of that, we can draw near to him
with confidence in our time of need
and our time of weakness.
And so when you are fighting against the desires
of the flesh, you can draw near to God
and pray for deliverance.
Here's what I want us to see through all those.
At the root of all these ways of escape is God himself.
God is so faithful to provide a way of endurance
that he has made himself the way God is for you.
In this fight, God is faithful
and we need to humble ourselves
and be reminded that he is the way of escape.
He is our hope and he is our defense.
He is our escape from the evil one.
And this just reminds me of the song, Lord, I need you.
It says, so teach my song to rise to you
when temptation comes my way,
and when I cannot stand, I will fall on you.
Jesus, you are my hope and stay.
And later on my one defense, my righteousness,
oh God, how I need you.
God is faithful in our temptations
so we can leave here ready to fight
by relying on God, relying on his spirit,
relying on his word,
and relying on prayer, praying for help.
But even though we have the tools
and the resources
to fight against temptation, we still struggle.
I still struggle. I still give a temptation
and sin against God who has made himself the way of escape.
Our track record against temptation is not in our favor.
So what can help us in this fight?
Knowing that we need to be reminded
that temptation did not overtake Jesus.
Amen. Temptation did not overtake Jesus.
And so we need to look two places for hope.
First, where were the people overthrown?
Where did they fall into temptation? Look at verse five.
They were overthrown in the wilderness.
Where did Jesus withstand temptation?
In Matthew four in the wilderness,
Jesus is reversing the curse.
So look to the wilderness.
Look at what Jesus did on our behalf,
but also look to the cross.
Jesus, the one who never fell into temptation,
died on the cross for people who constantly fall
and he saved us.
He gave us a new life by his blood.
Even though we struggle with temptation
and it can be hard, we need to focus our eyes on
what has already been done on our behalf.
God is faithful in the midst of temptation
and he's faithful on the other side of temptation
because Christ has reconciled us to him.
Do you believe that today? And if you have not
yet trusted in Jesus, I want you to see this,
that at the heart of his faithfulness is his love.
We serve a God who loves us so much
that he is faithful even in our temptations.
And I want to invite you to explore that, to come talk
to us about what that means.
That God himself will be faithful
To faithless people.
But if you are a believer
and you have trusted in Jesus Christ, fight
and flee from temptation, fight
and flee from sin, not in your own strength,
but by the strength of God, by his way of escape,
trust in his faithfulness, even in temptation,
one Corinthians 10, six through 13.
Now these things took place as examples for us
that we might not desire evil as they did,
do not be idolatry as some of them were as it is written,
that people sat down to eat and to drink
and rose up to play.
We must not indulge in sexual immorality as some
of them did, and 23,000 fell in a single day.
We must not put Christ to the test as some of them did
and were destroyed by serpents
nor grumble as some of them did
and were destroyed by the destroyer.
Now these things happen to them as an example,
but they were written down
for our instruction on whom the end of ages has come.
Therefore, let anyone who thinks that he stands
take heed Les he fall.
No temptation has overtaken you. That is not common to man.
God is faithful and he will not let you be tempted
beyond your ability.
But with the temptation, he will also provide the way
of escape that you may be able to endure it.